[Musique]
c'est samedi 26 mai au stade régional
gaby folio à petit il était organisée la
29e finale départementale du parcours
sportif des sapeurs pompiers des
épreuves athlétiques
cette compétition a réuni plus de 350
participants venus des quatre coins de
l'île au programme du lancer de poids
grimper de corde semble d'abord c'est un
jour de fête un jour de retrouvailles
puisque tous les sportifs du département
et bien sûr le ce très beau stade de
petite île mais pour dire alors pour des
épreuves sportives qui sont très
traditionnelle chez nous le disait
projette l'éthique et puis le parcours
le parcours du sapeur pompier quitte à
un parcours du combattant de sa
forfaiture
mais c'est avant tout un rassemblant
sportif où tous les sens tous les
pompiers qu'ils soient volontaires les
professionnels personnels administratifs
et techniques se retrouvent pour
pour une journée de détente et une
journée sportive les meilleurs athlètes
sélectionnés iront défendre les couleurs
du 19 7 4 et du département lors de la
finale nationale en métropole
[Musique]